hey what's up guys my name is Bettina
welcome back to my C++ series so it's
been a really long time since I lost a
bus bus episode but that does not mean
this series is over
haha Oh nor we in fact just getting
started there's just so much in C++ to
cover and in fact it's now 2020 which
means tables cost 20 is on the horizon
and of course I'm gonna have a bunch of
videos on that coming in the future
today though we're gonna be talking
about something that is less a language
feature of sabors plus and more of just
a design pattern and that is a singleton
what is a singleton why do I care why do
I want to use it when do I want to use
it all that stuff that's gonna be in
today's video but first I want to thank
our sponsor for this video hosting up
now everyone needs web hosting of some
sort whether you're an artist a
programmer anyone who just wants a
website on the Internet or some kind of
server technology to run code that
they've written you're gonna need some
sort of web hosting and my favorite
company for that by far is hosting it
and let me tell you why first of all I
absolutely love their control panel so
many web hosting companies have these
dream Lea complicated outdated web 2.0
looking like Chiyu eyes and all of that
to set up your website which is just
ridiculous if you just want to install a
quick WordPress site which I think that
honestly a lot of people should just do
and that'll be that'll be fine for them
it's as simple as just going to their
beautifully designed control panel and
just setting that up in just a couple of
clicks and in fact they have built-in
Diagnostics to help you in case
something goes wrong hosting are by far
the simplest in that regard they're also
extremely well Christ and by extremely
well priced I mean they're offering you
ninety one up to ninety one percent off
that's like I mean what even is that if
you sign up using the link in the
description below with my code ninety
one percent off web hosting really I
mean to be honest they're just they're
just one of my favorite sponsors to work
with because it's just such a good
product and it's sore sore sore
affordable go ahead and sign up using
that link in the description to get up
to 91 percent off all of their products
make 2020 the year that you find
get that website up and running because
because it's time and of course a huge
thank you to hosting it for being a
wonderful sponsor and sponsoring this
video
so Singleton's what is the deal with
Singleton's just left the monitor like
in the frame like what's going on sure
has been a while with these hippos Plus
videos okay so I'm gonna keep this real
simple as I'd like to do a singleton is
basically a single instance of a class
that you just have around and that's it
so it's a class way you only intend to
have a single instance of that class or
struct because classes and structs have
like pretty much the same thing in C++
now
object-oriented programming in general
the whole benefit of having these
objects these classes is the fact that
you can instantiate them multiple times
it's not just all about being like okay
I'm gonna write all of my code and then
I'm just gonna instantiate this object
and it's that's it like that I'm not
gonna instantiate more than one instance
of this object a little bit we're a
little bit counterproductive why do I
even need an object in the first place
and that's the thing if you are using a
singleton it's quite easy to just look
at it and be like well this does not
need to be a class because if you only
have a single instance of an object then
what you really have is just one
singular set of data and then probably
some functionality to go along with it
so in other words we have our class
members which represent our data and
then we have the other thing which is
all of the functions that represent you
know operations usually performed on
that specific set of data or otherwise
to interact with that data those are
kind of the two blobs we end up with and
if that is the case if we don't intend
to instantiate multiple instances of a
particular class and thus you know we
would want it's their own kind of
version of the data upon which those
operations will kind of be performed on
not to complicate things but if we don't
need that then why do why would we even
use a class now Java and c-sharp they're
inherently object oriented languages
that they kind of force that upon you
specifically Java I'm what I'm just
gonna just pick on Java for
in Java everything has to be a class you
can't have card outside of a class which
means that if you want this kind of
static will say functionality where you
don't actually need instantiation then
you have to just make static members in
your class and a static static group of
functions now we in C++ are not really
bound by those rules because we don't
have to write a class we can just have
functions that are you know part of some
kind of namespace or even in the global
namespace
that do not belong to any kind of class
and furthermore we can do the same thing
with variables we can have completely
global variables or we can have static
variables that are tied to a particular
translation unit or in other words a
particular CPP file C++ incredibly
flexible language lets us do whatever we
want but the singleton design pattern
where does that come into play
Singleton's super useful for when we
essentially want to have functionality
that applies to some kind of global set
of data that we just want to potentially
repeatedly reuse so a few really basic
examples of Singleton's a random number
generator class we just want to be able
to query it and be like give us a random
number we don't want to have to
instantiate it go through all of that
stuff nor because we potentially want to
instantiate it once so that it actually
seeds that random number generator and
sets up any other kind of axillary
things I guess that it actually needs
but then we want to just call some kind
of function that will give us a random
number based on what we've initialized
it with simple as that
another good example is something like a
renderer a renderer very commonly is a
very global thing we typically don't
have multiple instances of a renderer we
have a renderer to which we submit all
of these rendering commands and then it
just kind of well it renders things for
us if we break this down into like
OpenGL we're literally calling OpenGL
calls through our renderer potentially
that all in itself is a global set of
functions that's not something that
relate to some kind of object at all
they're just C style functions no
classes nothing to do with that at all
so what we want potentially is just to
be able to almost use the class as a
namespace to just call certain function
and that's where this whole singleton
thing gets a little bit messy and why I
really want to dive into some code and
take a look it's because ultimately
speaking Singleton's can just behave
like namespaces singleton classes can
just behave like namespaces there's
nothing to actually tie them to that
word class I'm gonna say this once very
clearly Singleton's in C++ are just a
way to organize a bunch of global
variables and Static functions that
sometimes may or may not act upon those
variables into one kind of organized
blob that is essentially under a single
namespace that is what that is what a
singleton is now of course it can be
flexible around those rules but that's
basically it let's just dive in and take
a look at some examples how we can write
a singleton and some other things along
the way so let's start out with a really
really basic example of a singleton
we'll just write a class we'll call it
singleton and then I'll kind of explain
everything that makes this singleton a
singleton so to start off with we don't
want to have a constructor because if we
have a constructor that is just public
then it's going to allow people to be
instantiated so what you would typically
do is just mark this constructor as
private meaning that this class can't be
instantiated outside of within this
class the next step is to provide a way
to actually access this class statically
so we would need some kind of static
function which returns either a
reference or a pointer of this
particular type and you typically call
it something like get instance or just
get for short and then what this needs
to do is return some kind of instance of
singleton now because it is a singleton
there is obviously just one instance of
this class for your entire application
so the way that you designed this is
completely up to you I'll show you a few
ways a more traditional way is just to
simply make a static instance of that
singleton class somewhere here inside
your private members so in other words I
would just make a static singleton
called something like s underscore
instance however because it is static it
needs to actually be defined somewhere
so in some kind of CPP file I would now
need to take this singleton and actually
define it like so like any kind of
static member and then once I've done
that inside my get function I can simply
return this s instance
this is kind of a very popular singleton
pattern this is probably something you
do especially in a language such as Java
you wouldn't exactly need this
definition but you would set it up this
way and what this means is that if I
have a main function over here I can
simply access that singleton by just
calling singleton get just like that and
then from within there if I had some
kind of function like a void function or
something like that then I can simply
just call the function on that singleton
instance and there we go I can
statically access this singleton as if
there was just one instance of it
because I can just use this get function
now semantically this does have a few
flaws for example I can just take this
singleton get function and assign it
into a completely separate singleton
instance so I can do something like this
what I probably meant to write in this
case is a singleton reference like this
because I can absolutely do this and
then use this instance over here like so
however if I accidentally forget to do
this what will actually happen is all of
this data inside the singleton will be
copied so in fact I've created an
additional singleton instance and if I
actually had data here like I had some
kind of member here then of course that
data would be copied into this new
object and that of course is not what a
singleton is it defeats the entire
purpose of a singleton I just want one
instance so to combat this what you
would typically do is simply delete the
copy constructor because if I come up
here and I just mark the copy
constructor as delete like this right
then it won't let me do this I have to
actually write this as a reference or
something like that using Auto is also a
completely valid thing to do but again
remember that you need to explicitly
write reference here and then you can
use it like so ok cool so this is a
completely arbitrary example hopefully
it makes sense let's deal with something
a little bit more real what I'm gonna do
is instead of this being a singleton
class which means nothing I'm gonna try
and make a random number generator class
so I'll just copy and paste all of this
stuff and then I'll just apply this over
here and let's just say that I want to
write a function that generates a random
float so I'll call this float float now
this is not a video
about random number generation so what
we'll do is we'll kind of just have our
random generator flirt here we'll just
set it to 0.5 and that is what this
function will return but pretend that of
course it would it's a real function
that randomly generates a number and
then returns it through this design if I
want to actually generate a random
number all I have to do is call random
yet and then float it and I'll get a
random float presumably and I can assign
this like so float number equals random
get float now this is totally legit and
it's a great use case of Singleton's
because you don't need to have multiple
instances of a random number generator
potentially I mean of course you could
justify that but for this case let's
just say we have a very simple random
number generator it gets seeded in the
beginning potentially and then just
reuse throughout our program simple as
that we don't need anything complex
let's kind of break this down and take a
look at what it actually consists of so
we have a deleted copy constructor we
have this get function and then we have
our actual kind of meet this is the
actual function that returns a class
member now this is one of the things
that make the singleton as singleton the
fact that this is an actual class and it
can have class members such as this
random generator if this just returned
some kind of static value like this then
of course it could simply be marked as
static and we wouldn't in fact need a
singleton at all but the thing that
makes a singleton a singleton is the
fact that it is in fact a class so it
can support all of these class features
such as class members you could
definitely look at this and see it as
being annoying because instead of just
calling random floor which might be
desirable I have to call random get and
then floor it which of course just adds
some more complexity I could kind of fix
this by just bringing this out and being
like order random equals random get and
then from there calling random float and
this might be something I do if I have
this whole kind of function scope where
I'm just gonna be using this random
number generator however of course that
is an extra line of code and it is a
little bit annoying so how do we get it
to this state and then obviously still
keep it as a singleton with class
members well what I like to do is simply
make another function so I have my kind
of implementation of what float is it
returns a random
generator what I'll do is I'll move this
actual function into the private section
here and I'll rename it so I'll call it
something like float internal or float
some people call it float in pool for
implementation I like to just stick an
eye out the front now this does kind of
make it look like an interface
potentially if you're using that
convention but I like using it for these
functions because I'm basically saying
that this is the internal float function
and then what I'll do our here is write
a static float function so this will be
static float float and then what this
will do is simply return yet dot I float
so I have this kind of indirection here
obviously once all of this gets in lined
by the compiler
you really shouldn't see any kind of
performance hit or anything from all
these function calls because in the end
we're just kind of retrieving the value
zero point five and that's it but what
that means for us is that we can in fact
run this code here and if I just print
this out to the console you can see that
I do get my value zero point five and
everything is fine and I haven't had to
call get at all so that's just like a
little hack that I like to use another
route you could go is simply just not
even worrying about this indirection
because all we're trying to do here is
return a value you can just return get
dot M underscore random generated that
way you don't need this internal
function at all but of course in a lot
of cases you probably want to keep this
internal functionality and the benefit
here obviously is that since it is not a
static function it has access to all of
the class members without having to like
retrieve you know the actual instance or
anything like that
so that's another benefit now the last
thing that I want to show is this kind
of get function here because the way
that we've written it right now means
that we actually need a static instance
over here in the class members and then
we need to define it in some kind of
translation unit that's a little bit
cumbersome I don't like to do it that
way a better way to do this is to
actually move this static declaration
inside this static function so what I
can do is get rid of this entirely as
well as this and then simply in this get
function I can write static random-ass
underscore instance and in fact like I
can just call it instance if I wanted to
that's totally fine as well so what this
is doing is actually having a static
variable inside a function which means
that this still is in fact in static
memory once they get
function gets called for the first time
it will be instantiated and then on
subsequent times it's just in static
memory so it'll just be reference it's
basically the same as what we did before
but you can see that it's a lot cleaner
because I don't need to have anything
here at all and functionally it's
identical if I come down over here and I
want to call random flirt which of
course goes through that get function
then obviously I'm going to get the
exact same result so that's pretty much
all there is to a singleton you probably
want to do a few other things to clean
it up and make it a little bit better
for example you might want to delete the
assignment operator as well but I've
just kind of simplified this and made it
a little bit easier to understand
so to summarize the core of a singleton
is this kind of functionality here where
I have a single instance that I create
once which in this case happens as soon
as it's used for the first time and then
the lifetime of this singleton would
simply be the lifetime of your
application and then once I have this
singleton I can simply write any any
amount of non-static methods and access
them via this get function or if I want
I can kind of remove one level of
indirection and write these static
functions which internally just map to
member functions which can access member
data and all of the functionality of
classes now the last thing I want to
show you guys is what happens if I just
don't treat this as a class what's the
point of even having a class in C++ why
can't I just write a namespace I'll call
it random class in this case that just
has all this functionality and the
answer is you can I can just write this
and I can write a static float called s
underscore random generator and you know
set this equal to 0.5 and then have a
function called float like this static
flirt floor which then returns s random
generator there's no functional
difference between having these two and
in fact if I just call random class
flirt here you'll see that it's
identical I mean I do have this extra
variable which is just tied to a
namespace instead of a class I do kind
of lose his private public functionality
but you can get around that if I had a
header file which just simply contained
a declaration for this function and then
I had a C++ file which implemented the
function and also had a static version
of this
then I've effectively hidden it from
other files but again there's no real
downside to using a class and of course
it does let you keep it a little bit
more organized not to mention that I do
in fact lose the functionality of being
able to assign the instance of this
class to like a variable like I did
before okay so hopefully that kind of
gives you a little bit more of an
example it's sometimes hard to just sit
here and talk are you guys even though I
have so much I want to say obviously a
lot easier to actually dive in and take
a look at the card itself hopefully you
guys enjoy this video if you did please
hit that like button don't forget that I
do have a patreon as well patreon come
for later the Cherno huge thank you to
everyone who helps support this channel
please let me know if you want to see
more kind of design pattern videos like
this singleton one if you have any
thoughts about Singleton's leave them in
the comment section below so that we can
have a nice discussion let me know if
you use them when you use them or use
them for if you don't like using them
and why all that stuff leave it in the
comment section below huge thank you
again to hosting it for sponsoring this
video guys check that web hosting out up
to ninety one percent off it's
incredible I will see you next time
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]